good evening we are seeing more signs of  recovery for the entertainment capital  of the world especially on the north end  of the las vegas strip  thanks for being here at six i'm denise  feldas good evening i'm brian loftis  wynn resorts has announced a new covit  vaccination  and testing policy for its employees now  the policy gives employees the option  of either completing a covit 19  vaccination  or obtaining weekly negative covid19  tests  approximately 60 percent of wynn las  vegas employees have  already been vaccinated ceo matt maddox  talked about the decision in a video  message  to his employees we want to be the  safest place in north america  for people to come and vacation and for  all of you to work day to day  i really look forward to seeing all of  you i look forward to  the good times that are just right  around the corner that are coming our  way